we're sure it that you love cooking just
as much as we do
you've got to hand it to the food
scientist who developed meals that are
ready to eat for the military while in
field operations there are truly a
technological marvel keep watching to
learn more about military MREs and make
sure you stay till the end to find out
how you can get your hands on a box or
two of ready to eat rations if this is
your first time visiting our channel
don't forget to subscribe and give this
video a big thumbs up today we're
showing you that this is what is freely
in military food what exactly is an MRE
MRE is an abbreviation for meal
ready-to-eat these are the meals that
our soldiers eat out in the fields they
may have no access to a canteen or
cafeteria these meals are full of
calories and nutrients in order to keep
our troops well-fed and strong providing
them with energy to do their fields
works with maximum capability these
amazing little power pouches are
waterproof
and also able to withstand high impact
forces both of which are necessary
requirements given the environment in
which you would typically find them
they're made to be tough and they have
long shelf lives to boot the United
States as MREs are more technically
advanced than any other food ration in
the world each MRE generally contains an
entree bread or a cracker a side dish
some sort of spread candy dessert and
something to drink
in addition to the food aspect every MRE
also typically comes with seasonings or
hot sauce a flameless ration heater and
miscellaneous accessories such as
utensils coffee creamer chewing gum and
matches currently soldiers can choose
among 24 different meal packages in the
MRE program each MRE is designed to give
a soldier 1/3 of their daily recommended
nutritional intake as for military
guidelines and soldiers are expected to
eat three meals a day in order to have a
hundred percent of their daily nutrient
value speech the MRE is the most
efficient method of feeding our troops
today as it's compact easy to transport
easy to prepare and nutritionally dense
the history of ready-to-eat meals in the
military during the Civil War
MREs were not that they are today they
were just called food rations back then
but the idea behind them was the same
they needed to be able to be preserved
easy to transport and nutritious one
example of a civil war ration consisted
of salted meat
Zorich usually pork or beef a compressed
cube of mixed vegetables and hardtack a
type of bread or cracker with an
extremely long shelf life the reason for
salting the meat is that the salt acts
as a very effective preservative salt
absorbs water red blood cells making it
an inhospitable environment for mold and
bacteria which rely on water to thrive
by the time of the first world war the
ten can't had been invented and proved
an ideal method of storing rations for
soldiers between the two world wars the
u.s. worked on developing new types of
rations based on nutrition after
conducting numerous surveys to assess
the health and diet of its soldiers the
final results three new rations the sea
ration consisting of Maine Mills the D
ration consisting of an unappetizing
nutritionally dense chocolate bar for
emergencies and the K ration which was a
smaller and lighter version of the C
ration in the 1980's the u.s. replaced
tin cans food rations with airtight bags
containing what we now know as the
modern meals ready-to-eat
how MREs are made military meals ready
to eat are made no differently than your
standard American dinner the only real
difference is what happens after the
food is made for your standard American
dinner the food is eaten straight away
but for MREs they need to be packaged
and preserved the process is really not
too foreign to preserving foods in tin
or aluminum cans and in fact it's
exactly the same process they do today
as they did when rations were contained
in cans if you're familiar with the
canning process then you already know
how it works for MREs once the food is
cooked and has been prepared it is
placed in its container yet a can or a
pouch the food is then boiled in its
container to kill the bacteria with heat
a process that works because the
proteins and the bacteria become
denatured proteins are useful to us
because different proteins come in
different shapes and these shapes are
very important to their function eating
them causes the bonds that hold these
shapes to break denaturing the protein
and causing the bacterial cell to die
once the food is sterile the container
is hermetically sealed and the food
remains sterile inside because new
bacteria are now unable to enter this
prolongs their shelf life and it doesn't
require any other special preparation
that makes the food pour into us such as
freeze drying or radiation treatment
it's still normal earth food to
sterilize how MREs are prepared in the
field now that we've taught you how MREs
are made it's time
teach you how they're prepared to be
eaten in the field the whole idea behind
MREs is they don't normally need
preparation you can just open the
package and begin your piece each meal
comes with plastic utensils to eat them
with so to prepare an MRE you just open
the box take out the pouch with the food
you want to eat first
open it and chow down they can be
touched up with provided seasoning our
sauces like hot sauce to taste better to
each MRE also comes with salt and pepper
because every meal tastes better with a
personal touch to taste it's important
to note that most of our soldiers prefer
to eat their MREs hot even though
they're perfectly safe to eat without
further preparation and let's be honest
here how many of you prefer a hot meal
to cold leftovers any day there's a
reason so many offices have microwave
heating up meals over an open flame can
be time-consuming and depending on where
the soldiers are stations potentially
dangerous
the military has fortunately devised a
clever method of heating up MREs without
the use of fire turning to the wonders
of chemistry to produce an extra thermic
reaction that eats the meal totally
flame free we'll tell you about that now
the flameless ration heater the
flameless ration heater or frh for short
is a food heating device patented by a
company called zest o therm and it was
created specifically for the US military
to keep their rations without fire and
in an environmentally friendly way the
fr H itself is compact weighing just
over an ounce and measuring no more than
five and a half inches long by four and
a half inches wide and it's less than
half an inch thick their one-time use
but can last for five years until use
the F RH is activated by water and their
reaction is exothermic meaning that it
releases heat as a byproduct the sealed
MRE is meant to be placed into a
designated bag the flameless ration
heater water is then poured into the bag
until the fill line the heater and MRE
are slid to the bottom of the bag the
bag is sealed and the soldier is
required to fumble with the bag a bit
until the heater has soaked up all the
water a process which takes about one
minute the entire bag assembly can then
be placed back into the original carton
in which the MRE pouch is packaged and
left to heat for about 10 to 12 minutes
it's important to knead the MRE
afterwards to ensure the heat has been
evenly dispersed and then you have your
piping hot meal ready to eat the MRE
menu today today's MREs are no more
foreign to us than what you might find
on an America
dinner-table on any given night the menu
consists of 24 meals divided between two
cases case a containing meals 1 through
12 piece B containing milk 13 through 24
inside these boxes of the individual
meal pouches and within these meal
pouches you will find the main ports
beside a dessert drink crackers
condiments utensils supplies and gum
just to name a few items the menu has
more or less remain the same in the last
decade and even a little earlier a few
examples of the main course meals
provided in the MREs would be beef
brisket fettuccine with spinach
mushrooms with cream sauce Asian style
beef strips for vegetables veggie
crumbles with pasta and a taco style
sauce and Southwest beef and black bean
the menu caters to meat lovers and
vegetarian delight as well as providing
kosher and halal options to cater to the
expansive diversity of the US military
MREs include beverages such as coffee
tea and milkshakes as well military food
is starting to sound not so bad the menu
was created with efforts to keep the
party and hell coal fighting not just
the required nutrients for military
lifestyle for the comforting cakes at
home that soldiers in a different
territory may desire nutritional content
because soldiers abroad typically
sustain themselves almost exclusively
MREs these quick meal needed to be
designed daily vitamin and mineral
intake values behind what kind of diet
somebody in the military needs how many
calories and how many grams of carbs
proteins and fats with someone living in
this active lifestyle need these
questions were inspected and answered
around the time of the Second World War
and today food scientists have a pretty
good answer while the numbers vary an
MRE is an average of 1250 calories of
those calories around 13% comes from
protein
36% from fats and 51% from carbohydrates
again this is not the exact numerical
breakdown for each individual meal but
an average a complete meal includes the
main dish each side drinks desserts
crackers everything in the package so in
order to benefit with all the nutrients
it's
soon everything all of this nutritional
information is available to soldiers on
the individual packaging of each item we
can consume we're the eagerly curious
groups the information is also available
in an online database provided by
Defense Department's Human Performance
Resource Center and army researchers
this gives soldiers more opportunity to
control and manage their own diets which
might not necessarily be a top priority
concern for those out in the fields but
it is an option nonetheless storage and
shelf-life meals-ready-to-eat
need to be as tough as the Warriors who
are meant to eat them they need to be
durable and they need to be able to last
a long time without spoiling even in
harsh conditions such as sweltering arid
regions the shelf life of an MRE varies
depending mainly on the temperature in
which it's stored if stored at a higher
temperature its shelf life decreases the
decrease is exponential for example if
an MRE is stored at a hundred degrees
Fahrenheit it will have a shelf life of
around six months drop the storage
temperature by only twenty degrees to a
comfortable 80 Fahrenheit however and an
MRE can last three years if stored in a
cool environment stay around fifty
degrees or cooler
their shelf life has the potential to
reach five years or more fortunately if
you're not too sure about the storage
conditions of your MRE and want to know
if it's still good to eat a time
temperature indicator or TTI for short
was placed on boxes in the 90s this TTI
consists of two circles a dark outer
circle and a light inner circle as long
as the circle on the outside remains
darker than the one on the inside
PMR you should still be good in theory
packaging the reason MREs can last for
such extended periods of time is due to
their packaging it's like a high-tech
flexible tin can we're sure some of you
viewers have non-perishable canned goods
sitting in your pantry that you bought a
year or two ago that are still good so
you know just how the food contents have
been sterilized to last the MRE is
contained in what is called four quart
packaging this type of packaging
consists of layers of metal and plastic
specifically polyester aluminum foil and
polypropylene which creates a strong
flexible container that seals the
sterilized food inside for years in
addition to providing a long shelf life
this type of packaging is also extremely
tough it's waterproof impact resistant
and able to withstand a fall from a
hundred feet the flat and flexible
design of the pouch
to be superior to the caning method of
military's past it stores more
efficiently within its flat nature and
it also takes less time to heat to a
point of sterilization than a can would
this is because the volume is spread
across a greater surface area rather
than being tightly packed in a thick pan
this typically results in food that
tastes better since it didn't need to be
heated for as long the pouches are also
lighter than cans and all in all they
have become a much better substitute to
the previous method of rationing food to
soldiers use outside of the military
MREs don't just exist for soldiers there
exist many companies that sell civilian
MREs to a large community of
survivalists also known as Preppers
people who prepare for disaster or
apocalyptic situations additionally
during times of natural disasters such
as after deadly hurricanes or
earthquakes MREs are usually passed out
to feed civilians who have lost their
homes because the original MRE line is
government property it's not available
to civilians for purchase however there
are five major companies creating and
selling their own marks of
meals-ready-to-eat that you can
conveniently order online they don't
have as buried a menu as the US
military's MRE program does but this is
understandable given that civilian MREs
are for preparedness in the event of an
emergency
instead of daily consumption the
mechanisms of civilian MREs are
essentially identical to that of the
military MREs sterilize food and durable
packaging that comes with a spoon and if
you desire a heater to enjoy your meal
hot the shelf life of different brands
of MREs vary between themselves and
they're also different from the shelf
life of military MREs civilian MREs tend
to last a touch longer than those of the
military keeping with the pattern of
longer shelf life when stored at lower
temperatures at the end of the day some
people may find it comforting to know
they have food stored away in their cold
basement in the event of an emergency
that wraps it up for the lowdown on
military food and meals ready-to-eat
if you enjoyed learning about how
soldiers eat make sure to check out ten
times people absolutely won the food
lottery to relish in the times people
got way more bang for their buck thanks
for watching
[Music]